I've been praying for a but for 26 years
finally finally I got was it was a
common thing to be told you're Cuban
because you don't have a bed okay cute
things all right let me see the bags
like that doesn't happen to me
guys if we go this oh nevermind people
would always make comments like oh she's
so skinny she's so bony she has no booty
I don't care what I look like other than
like feeling good on the inside
at first glance they look like my
grandma's bloomers offenders is padding
I can see you like how through clothing
this could feel like a booty this is
like an a second bra they're not cute I
have a butt finally I got wood oh and it
actually looks really natural I don't
look like Kim Kardashian I look like
like a normal human which is which is
awesome
it just looks fake I look like I did one
too many squats I just like dance you
know I just want to like go to the club
like where is the club at makes me want
to do my favorite Sierra move it looks
like I have to really take a strip oh my
god good job guys whoever made that I
was like looks good there's another one
I thought this was a jockstrap
I guess these parts cup underneath the
butt fish like I'm a transformer first
of all my butt looks like a hexagon dad
you're wrong I think I did it wrong it
like is a permanent wedgie - which is so
terrible there's like major strategy
going on and it looks like my ass cheeks
just like got chiseled off this still
looks like my butt just listed which I
guess makes sense I'm getting major
panty line what are you wearing this
with and it's like pushing skin in other
places like weirdly if you're gonna wear
something to make your body look better
and it's gonna take you 10 minutes and a
little bit of sweat to get it on it
better look damn good and this doesn't
look damn good at all my lung is over
here now see it's all been pushed back I
just want to get out of this please I
can't I think it's okay if people use
but enhance it if it's gonna enhance
your confidence along with your body I'm
all for it okay if you're already
feeling good about yourself sometimes
that's not a bad thing I don't already
have a lot of stuff to put on in the
morning this afro alone takes like 45
minutes to deal with so I really don't
have time to like search for my morning
butt pad I like my little button I
cannot lie